in this video i'm going to be talking to
you about how to fix the character
traits and deficiencies that you have in
your life so whether it be struggling
with
anxiety or
happiness and depression
or being a bad husband or being money
focused or whatever the thing is that
you claim to have a problem with i'm
going to give you really the only mental
framework that has ever worked for me
if you're new to the channel my name is
alex from rosie i own acquisition.com to
portfolio of companies is about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you
i make these videos because candidly i
enjoy sharing some of the things that
have helped us kind of get through
things as we've grown our companies and
there are a lot of people who are broke
and i don't want you to be one of them
and so i'm going to probably piss a lot
of people off in this video so i'm going
to give you a heads up second thing is i
will be cussing in this video so if you
have kids around um i would say you know
mute it or listen to it another time so
i was talking to an entrepreneur the
other day and uh they were saying that
they were having panic attacks right and
they were struggling with this issue
what i want to do is walk you through um
the process that i was explaining to
them now at this point they the reason
the the panic attacks started for this
entrepreneur ironically um is that they
were talking to a therapist and the
therapist was like let's look at your
past and dug up you know crap about
their past and then they started looking
at this thing and then they started
getting you know anxiety kind of
remembering all these these kind of past
experiences and whatnot here's the thing
most therapists and i say this with zero
degree most therapists are humans and
most humans suck at most things
especially things they think they're
good at and so most of them are just
normal people who did okay in school and
now just like talking to people and
don't have any [ __ ] clue what they're
doing all right so here's the deal
here's the hot take what most of them
will do is they will try and pull
something up and say something to the
extent of what do you make that mean
what does that mean to you the thought
process behind this is hey you have this
thing it's triggering a feeling it's
because you think that having anxiety
makes you a bad person or makes you a
bad entrepreneur or whatever thing that
you say it has meaning right what do we
make this mean all right that's the
question what are you making this mean
all right so if you have problems and
this is especially important with
cyclical behavior reinforcing behavior
this is also one of the reasons that i
actually do not stand for the whole aaa
concept of standing up in front of
people every morning and say hi
everybody i am an adult i [ __ ] hate
it it's literally like owning this
deficiency and incorporating it and
weaving into your contract and your
identity and you reinforce it every
[ __ ] morning it's insanity to me the
way to stop being addicted to something
is to stop thinking about it
like what does it look like to not be
addicted it looks like you just
continuing to live your life not even
thinking about it what does it look like
to not have anxiety it's not you doing
your anti-anxiety routine in the morning
and say i suffer from anxiety or i
struggle with anxiety it's not saying
that and saying i have to do these
things i must i should i i need to in
order to not have anxiety because then
you're thinking about anxiety you give
anxiety
power and so what i'm going to walk you
through is the way
to hold the space and own the power that
you have in your own mind outside of the
thing that you were projecting the power
onto the process that these therapists
that are [ __ ] retards will do is they
will lead you through this thing where
they try and transform meaning they say
instead of saying it means you're a bad
person what if we just said this is you
know
it's a good thing or it's not a bad
thing right so we're trying to transform
meaning and i think that's like level
one elementary you know grade school of
of cognitive behavioral therapy right i
think that's grade school but the thing
is and this is the problem because i've
gone through the cycle which is why i'm
speaking about this so passionately and
i'll tell you a quick story before i
dive in so there was a period of time in
my life where i was very unhappy all
right and so i obsessed about happiness
right i read all the positive psychology
journals i read the the books i read the
happiness equation i mean like i went
through all of these things and yet
after spending all of this time trying
to obsess about happiness i was no less
no more happy and so then i thought to
myself well in one instance i can spend
lots of time and effort and be unhappy
or i can spend zero time and effort and
be unhappy well this one cost me less i
might as well start pursuing this and
this is what happened i adopted this
mentality and i will share it with you
called [ __ ] happiness all right bear
with me and so what ended up happening
is that i thought these thoughts and and
whenever uh the idea of is this making
me happy and all of these normal trigger
thoughts i'd be like oh i'm not happy
this isn't good i feel sad blah blah
blah
i would literally have this trump card
that i would just pop in my head and be
like [ __ ] happiness and i keep moving
the difference
between
[ __ ] happiness and let's think about how
we should be grateful for things is that
when you say [ __ ] happiness or [ __ ] the
thing that you are struggling with [ __ ]
anxiety [ __ ] whatever is that it no
longer has power because we're not
trying to transform
the meaning of the behavior we are
eliminating the meaning behind it all
together we are transforming it
into nothing and so hear me out for a
second and i don't know why this is
getting all spacey and weird i've tried
to fix this thing a hundred times the
reason this is so important all right is
that when you enter these vicious
reinforcing cycles so let's say it's
like oh god uh i'm afraid i'm gonna have
a panic attack tonight i don't wanna
have a panic attack you start thinking
about having a panic attack and then of
course you have a panic attack because
the fear of the thing is what reinforces
the cycle and you can do this with
anything right it could be it could be a
guy with erectile dysfunction like i
hope it doesn't happen i hope it doesn't
happen and then it happens right because
you're worried about it happening not
because the happening itself is the
thing right and i'm trying to use
examples that purposefully people derive
shame from because the thing is is that
the shame of the occurrence is the thing
that gives it power and so if you remove
the shame and by the way the way to
remove shame is to shed light on it
so nothing can give you shame if you
admit it openly
think about it if everyone knows the
thing
and you accept the thing or deem the
thing
meaningless
then it no longer has powerful over you
so let me let me give you an example
so this entrepreneur that i was talking
about earlier they were telling me that
they were having you know they're having
anxiety and it was preventing them from
sleeping et cetera right
and i was like so they're like well you
know i'm really working on it i was like
why and they like looked at me
cross-eyed and i was like how long have
you been working this you know like you
know eight months and i was like
are you less anxious than you were
before they're like well i think a
little bit
and i was like do you think you would be
a little bit less anxious if you just
did jack [ __ ] and waited eight months
from when you went from when you were
bad until now
they were like well maybe i was like
time does heal lots of wounds i was like
so you spent all this time to get this
little outcome and you could have just
let time happen and probably had the
same outcome
right right i was like but let's take it
one step further
why didn't you tell me how many bowel
movements you had yesterday
i mean i didn't think it was relevant
exactly so why are you sharing with me
that you have panic attacks because you
think it's meaningful
you derive meaning your brain is telling
you that this is something that is a
problem
so the thing is is that the deeming of
the thing a problem is the problem and
trying to change it or transform the
meaning into something else
is in my opinion just as bad because the
way that you created the mess that you
are in in a vicious cycle of
reinforcement is that you found a thing
and then you said i will give this
meaning and then you spend the rest of
your time trying to transform the
meaning when if you want to solve the
problem the experience of having the
problem solved is to not think about the
problem at all what it is is actually
reversing the process that created
meaning to begin with which is removing
meaning altogether i'm saying this
because i've had so many things that
i've struggled with in my life that i
would consistently obsess about over and
over and over again oh i don't want to
have that happening ah i don't wanna
have that happen again and then it would
happen and so in my opinion
the only way
to overcome these issues
is to you can you can slap the [ __ ]
happiness concept on it but it's to
destroy the meaning of the thing itself
and let it shrink into irrelevance
most my opinion most of the
psychological problems that we deal with
are better dealt with
not by trying to directly combat them
but by
not giving them the power of our
attention and there's a big difference
here i'm not saying the thought of
anxiety comes up you say i don't want to
think about it because then it's fear
fear gives it power
shame gives it power it's not that it's
looking at it and saying why are you
bringing this up this is irrelevant this
is a non-issue
and so for the same reason that you can
have noise in the background and you
don't think about it is that it's just
noise
and so what we do is we shrink
the thing from being a signal that our
brain deems meaningful
to noise that is in the background that
we no longer ascribe meaning to
altogether
and that is how it eventually shrinks
into a relevance and then we only choose
to allocate our attention towards the
thing that we find meaningful right and
so when what happened in my little [ __ ]
happiness story is that i said this is
no longer a productive conversation
i'd be like i'm unhappy like [ __ ]
happiness whatever i'm gonna keep moving
and a funny thing happened a few years
later i looked up and i realized that i
was significantly more happy than i was
before or as i prefer to say i was
significantly less unhappy
which also gives less power to the thing
altogether a different point that i want
to bring up because i think it's equally
important around this this topic a lot
of the fear and the shame comes from
perceived judgment that we have from an
anonymous outside society right we have
a voice or a series of voices that we
believe exist that only exist in our
mind that are judging us based on this
behavior that we are suffering from one
of the reasons
that i like to own the deficiencies
publicly is not because of you guys it's
for me
i own
like for example when i had uh you know
when we were we were running and growing
our our first big business which was the
licensing business i was always up front
i said i'm here to make money and the
reason i said that was so that i would
have no shame
in making money
because then if people in the future
were going to say something like alex is
only here to make money i would then
look at them and say and
so here hear me out
listen to this dialogue
let's say i was attacked because the
attacks that i'm saying i'm going to
portray as though it's outside but it's
inside of our minds that we attack
ourselves right so let's say somebody
comes up to me a woman and says you're a
terrible husband
most people say that there are two forms
of defense against this number one is
saying no no i'm not a bad bad a bad
husband right and then giving all the
reasons why i'm a good husband the other
way to defend against that would be to
say well you know being a husband is not
necessarily such a bad thing
right and so one is to dispute the other
is to alter right we're altering the
meaning behind the thing the first is
we're combating and we're saying that
we're not the thing but still
allowing the thing to have meaning
allowing a bad husband to be a negative
connotation that we ascribe meaning to i
think this is meaningful and i it's
negative but meaningful and so i will
say i am not that thing or
version two is this thing is meaningful
but i i understand it and interpret
differently right those are the two ways
the second way is how most therapy works
and i also think that it's [ __ ]
and so here's door number three
is that you look at the thing in the
face and you say and
i think you're a bad husband and
you're right
and
and watch
them shrivel
they will be paralyzed because
everything that they have exists to have
a counter force but if there is no
counter force for it to react to the
thought process stops and so if you
struggle with these vicious
recurring consistent dialogues and and
arguments in your head about what's good
and why should change and why you need
to be different and why this shouldn't
be this way just look at it in the eyes
and say and
and i'm going to give you a really
controversial example of what i think
should have happened in a public
scenario tiger woods
he was outed you know what i mean or
ousted or whatever it is you know what i
mean he was publicly shamed for
the the cheating thing right
and mind you this is not me condoning
cheating this is me to illustrate a
position of power
and this is a public demonstration of
power
but you can take it in terms of how you
can internally project that power onto
the idea that you want to vanquish all
right and we don't vanquish it by
transforming it we vanquish it by
eliminating the meaning altogether and
letting it shrink into irrelevance
so what tiger in my opinion should have
done in that situation when they said
you banged all these girls and you were
lying and blah blah blah he should have
said yes
i'm a liar and a cheater
but i'm the best [ __ ] golfer there is
next question what do they say
when you accept it there is no
conversation
and so try this in the next argument you
have with someone a but more importantly
with yourself is that someone says i
think you're x y and z and you said
you're right just give the power just
just say sure you're right
now what and
so
your point
when your brain tells you something that
you don't like or that you don't want to
look at
instead of trying to make it into
something else
liking it
to an irrelevant
observation
brain why didn't you bring up that i
have brown hair because it doesn't
matter
brain why didn't you bring up how many
bowel movements had yesterday this
doesn't matter
brain why didn't you say tell me how
many uh how many stairs i went up
yesterday
because it doesn't matter you don't find
it meaningful
and so why am i now deeming this thing
to be meaningful it's irrelevant to me
it's it it halts the conversation and it
stops the cycle
i say this and i know that i got
passionate about this but i say this to
someone who struggled with this for a
very long time and so the only
psychotherapy that i was able to do was
on myself
and it was not through talking out all
of these things and i know that a lot of
people get triggered a lot of people
want to say hey i have a therapist they
changed my life good for you that's
awesome keep doing it i don't care what
i'm doing is i'm trying to talk to
people who have not had that or have
done that and it's and it did not work
for them all right and so i'm sharing
the single most powerful mental model
that has worked for me
which is
purposefully staring at the problem and
saying
so what
your move
and watch it shrivel
and then moving on the [ __ ] with your
life
so anyways i love you all mozy nation
appreciate you thank you for giving me
the attention that you did today i make
these videos because i just i i
i hope that some of the lessons that
that that have served me uh can serve
some other people at least and if you're
in a darker place or you're struggling
with something like anxiety or
struggling with shame around some sort
of activity that you have done
i can tell you the only way to struggle
to deal with shame is to shed light on
it
shade shame only
exists in darkness
and the only way something has power is
when we fight it
because we deem it meaningful or worth
combating
and so i think the only way to truly
fight it is to not fight it at all and
say it is not a fight worth having
and then it will evaporate
and so anyways my friends keeping
awesome
lots of love i'll see you guys next
video bye